eric swalwell characteristically blew a
lot of hot air
on capitol hill yesterday and that's all
well and good that's just sort of what
he does every day
unfortunately though for mr swalwell and
all of his democrat colleagues
he was doing this in the face of bill
barr
and it didn't go very well for him now
mr barr are you investigating donald
trump for commuting the prison sentence
of his longtime friend and political
advisor roger stone
no why not
why should i well let's talk about that
it wasn't ready for a simple question
why should i do the thing you're asking
me to do
okay well yeah okay yeah let's okay we
can talk about that we can talk we will
talk about that
because bill barr the honey badger just
absolutely knocked down every democrat
on capitol hill yesterday
like he's just a human bowling ball
going down
the lane we will we will get into all of
it i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show yesterday
yesterday we asked people
just to entertain us on the show just to
get out just let us know what you think
about the news
my favorite comment from francois osungo
michael according to the left standards
anyone who says
that female doctor from the white coat
summit
is lying or promoting fake news is a
racist and hates women period
no francois what you misunderstand is
that you can only be racist
or sexist when you are contradicting the
left
whatever the left is saying that does
you can it's actually totally fine and
the big tech right now is censoring all
of that white coat lab summit that was
promoting hydroxychloroquine
we'll get to what that means not just
for coronavirus but also
for our politics also for the
2020 election but first bill barr
bill barr went to capitol hill
coincidentally i actually was with
the attorney general barr when
he accepted this invitation so you
remember i went to dc with senator cruz
and we did this episode of the verdict
podcast there at the doj with attorney
general barr
and that like as i get to the room as
bill bar gets to the room the news
breaks that he's going to accept the
democrats invitation to testify in
capitol hill
i have been waiting for many weeks for
this to happen because i knew it was
going to be absolutely hilarious
and it did not disappoint so my favorite
of the interrogators was eric swalwell
because you're eric swalwell i'm eric
well
we're all eric swalwell as you remember
from his presidential campaign
it went from bad to worse for mr
swalwell here's just a
little snippet of the interactions
between
congressman swalwell and the attorney
general
i know a lot about the law and various
other lawyers
i'm well educated well versed i know
that situations like this
real estate wise they're very complex
actually
they're pretty simple the forms are all
standard boilerplate
okay well we're all hungry we're gonna
get to our hot plate soon enough all
right
but let's talk about the contract here
sorry i forgot where did you go to law
school again
uh well i could ask you that very soon i
went to harvard mm-hmm how about you
where i'm pleading the fifth sir i'd
advise that you do that and i'll take
that advice into cooperation
all right now let's say you and i go
toe-to-toe in bird law and see who comes
out the victory you know i don't think
i'm gonna do anything um
close to that and i can see clearly you
know nothing about the law it seems like
you have a tenuous grasp on the english
language in general
okay well filibuster uh i'm sorry that
was not the clip of eric swalwell and
bill barr that was from
it's always sunny in philadelphia it
couldn't have been the clip between
swalwell and barr
because charlie day was much much more
articulate
and was making much much more sense than
eric swalwell was yesterday
i i frankly i wish we could just play
the entire interaction there
unfortunately it's not enough time
just a little snippet to give you the
idea of the difference here
not just in iq but difference in
seriousness
of purpose you don't read the
president's tweets no
well there's a lot of evidence in the
president's treats mr attorney general i
think you should start reading them
because he said
mr stones showed guts but on july 10
of this year roger stone declared to a
reporter
i had 29 or 30 conversations with trump
during the campaign period
trump knows i was under enormous
pressure to turn on him
it would have eased my situation
considerably but i didn't
the prosecutors wanted me to play judas
i refused are you familiar with that
stone statement
actually i'm not so how can you sit here
and tell us
why should i investigate the president
of the united states if you're not even
aware of the facts concerning the
president using the pardon or
commutation power
to swap the silence of a witness
because we we require you know a
reliable predicate before we open a
criminal investigation
and i just gave to you something i don't
consider it i consider it a very rube
goldberg theory that you had well it
sounds like
you're hearing this and by the way i
applied
there's going to be a lot could be a lot
more people under investigation
just absolutely devastating
because it gives this whole great
oration and bar is looking at him like
why what mistakes have i made in life
that have led me to have to sit in this
chair and listen to
all of you people you vacuous imbeciles
you democrats of capitol hill and he's
sitting there and he lets eric swalwell
finish
and swallow says so why haven't you
investigated the president
because um because we need a reliable
predicate to investigate
uh congressman swan do you know what an
investigation is a filibuster filibuster
i don't
i don't think that eric swalwell knows
very much of what he's talking about and
then the zinger at the end
and and if you watch the clip you can
see the attorney general's eyes
dart to the other members of the panel
he said if we were
going to take that flimsy standard as
the basis for investigations
then a lot more of you people
would be under investigation and that
more or less ends anything even
resembling substance
in the exchange and frankly i've got to
give eric swalwell credit because at
least eric swalwell
let the attorney general speak at the
hearing
that he was called to so that the
democrats could hear him that
unfortunately the other members of
congress did not seem to understand that
which we'll get to in just one moment
but first i got to thank our friends
over at ring
you know it's very important to know who
is at your door
whether you are home or whether you are
at the office or whether on your
vacation somewhere
i think these days a lot of us are home
more than usual
and it's still hard to keep a close eye
on things more deliveries mean more
boxes left
unattended and more opportunities for
packages to go missing
a lot can happen outside your front
doors we're not always free to check on
things
in person with ring you can keep your
home safe no matter where you are
especially you know things are just a
little weird these days okay
it's very good to be able to check in on
that sweet little lisa is a great shot
but i just
i want to be able to check in from my
phone anywhere this
is something that i give to my friends
as a housewarming gift
the reason i do that is one because it
makes you feel like you're in the future
and you know it keeps you very safe but
two it's inexpensive
and so you feel like a really cool guy
and you look like a great friend when
you give this to people
for their housewarming you can get a
special offer right now in the ring
welcome kit when you go to ring.com
knowles the welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell 3 and chime pro
it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today a
lot of people are not feeling safe these
days
make sure you feel safe with everything
that's going on go to ring dot com
slash knowles k wlas that is ring.com
knowles can wlas
swalwell at least let the attorney
general speak his colleagues
not so much greg price over at the daily
caller
put together just a very brief clip
of some of the democrats cutting off
bill barbie is what they would do they'd
give their orations that were supposed
to be
questions for the attorney general and
then at the end they wouldn't even let
the guy
answer they would just say okay you know
don't say that i don't like what you're
starting to say
i'm reclaiming my time i wasn't
claiming my time in april sometimes is
when does something actually become
reclaiming my time i'm site this is not
a trick question
in this country i'm reclaiming my time
as the general specific
without any remedy i'm reclaiming my
time let me share with you so you gotta
let him in reclaiming my time
you're reclaiming my time sir reclaiming
my time
but he found reclaiming my time without
political bias he said
and in april reclaiming my time mr
journey in
reclaiming mr barr
i'm pleased to know that the democrats
of capitol hill at least
know and can pronounce three words i
don't know that their
vocabulary and their intellect goes much
further than that but they at least can
say
reclaiming my time those are the three
words that they
can say and they can't hear very much
either the reason they can't hear very
much is
is an issue that plays in not just to
these democrats on capitol hill
but into a broader culture which is that
we are living in echo chambers
and if you're on the left you never even
hear the arguments that the right is
making
so it's no surprise that these democrat
congressmen don't want to let the
attorney general speak
they won't let him speak because they
are utterly
unprepared for what he has to say they
are utterly unprepared to answer what he
has to say
and they don't care what he has to say
it doesn't matter it's not going to
affect the way that the left which
controls
every major institution of power is
going to march
on and on and on at a certain point
billboard joked about this
to the members there he said hold on
who's who's doing the hearing he was
doing the talk and who's doing the
hearing
it is not a self-defining term as they
only got two minutes
that they recognized mr barry yeah but
this is a hearing i thought i was of one
that was supposed to be heard well let
me
and i'm gonna get there well you thought
wrong mr attorney general
this purpose of this entire hearing
is so that democrats can get little
clips for their re-election campaigns
where they're scolding the attorney
general and they're going to cut that up
and take that back home
and put it on television or put it on
the internet and
it is as always the left does
you know the left always projects so
whatever they're doing they're going to
accuse their opponents of doing
jerry nadler who's chairing this whole
circus comes out
and he accuses bill barr
of participating in campaigning here
by trying to get little video clips for
the president's reelection
the president wants footage for his
campaign ads
and you appear to be serving it up to
him as ordered
what are you talking about jerry
you're the one doing the whole purpose
of this hearing that you invited bill
barr to
is so that you all can get footage for
your re-election campaigns
and yet he's accusing the president of
doing the opposite thing
the only thing we learned yesterday and
it wasn't something new i guess we were
just reminded of it
is that congressman i and i i should
limit this to the democrats because the
republicans actually performed very well
yesterday
but these democrat congressmen who
wouldn't even let their guests speak
are vacuous imbeciles but it's not just
their fault
this we live in a sort of vacuous
culture a vapid culture
we all participate in it every last one
of us i saw this yesterday i don't know
if you've been following
on instagram there's this trend that has
taken over instagram
many of my dearest friends are doing it
so i'm not i want to poke too sharp fun
here
women are are taking
hot black and white selfies of
themselves i guess most selfies are of
yourself
they're taking these selfie photos and
then they're uploading it to instagram
and they're saying challenge accepted
and so all the all the women on
instagram were doing this and i thought
oh it's another one of these social
media challenge things okay
what's the challenge and so i'm looking
and i
i found out the challenge is to upload
a hot selfie that is
it's not that's not part of the
challenge or the medium of the challenge
that's the whole challenge is to get
women
on an app that exists solely for women
to put up hot pictures of themselves
the challenge is for women to put up hot
pictures of themselves
there is not even a nominal social
justice tie-in you know
most of these challenges there's like at
least a little hook it's like yeah
upload a hot selfie and then and then
you'll cure
a disease you know upload a hot selfie
to stop polio and you're like well i
don't really see the connection between
those two things but
at least but this one it's not even that
it's just just vanity
that's all it is it's just women
uploading photos of themselves
and saying i'm beautiful i'm strong and
i nominate and then you name
all these other women that you you also
suggest
should upload hot photos of themselves
and then the other women
they post the photos and they say thank
you for nominating me
thank you for challenging i'm i feel so
challenged
so anyway the other night i put up one
of myself and i don't know frankly i
thought it was
it was one of the more scintillating
challenging things i've ever done i feel
really lifted up and empowered also is
it
is it empowering to upload a hot selfie
for other people to walk over is that
that that is many things but i'm not
convinced
that that is empowering what's funny now
they're trying to add
a a kind of social justice element to it
so it's so all these women are uploading
the photos just for themselves just say
like i'm beautiful you're strong you go
girl
we don't we don't need anybody's
attention also look at my hot pictures
so that's the the thing that everyone's
doing now
then some women in turkey got upset
because apparently a few weeks ago there
was a campaign in turkey
to upload black and white photos to stop
women from
being killed or something to that effect
has nothing to do with what the women in
america are doing
and they're getting angry because they
feel like it's being taken over and this
reminds me of the black square you
remember all these
mostly white liberals were uploading the
black squares during black lives matter
and they were doing it to stand in
solidarity with blm and then the blm
people got angry because it was messing
up their hashtag or something right it's
just
you can't you can't win for a losing
first of all
and especially in the case of the black
and white photo what are we what's the
point
the point is is uh vanity
and and we all do it i'm not even
exempting myself i mean i don't i don't
do it when it comes to posting
hot selfies but we all do it in some
ways we all
indulge this vanity in this culture
that's what that whole hearing was
yesterday that's what much of our public
policy is right now is the indulgence
of vanity and you have a guy like bill
barr
getting back to bill barr you have a guy
like bill barr who is the voice of one
in the wilderness
crying out with any sort of common sense
and that man
in this crazy culture that man seems
like a lunatic
because he's speaking common sense to a
culture that's lost its mind we'll get
to that in one second
first i gotta thank our friends over at
puretalk
you know you should not assume that your
monthly cell phone bill
is like unnecessary
forever there's no way to fight it sort
of thing
your monthly cell phone bill should be
less than it is now who is your wireless
provider
at t verizon maybe t-mobile
what if i told you that puretalk usa
uses
the exact same network as one of those
carriers
i'm not saying it's a similar or a
compre i'm saying it's the exact same
one
same tower same exact coverage but it
costs you
half the price people love pure talk usa
sarah from abilene texas says the
service is amazing love the price the
speed is quick
the reception is so perfect switching is
so easy you can keep your phone
they'll just send you a sim card so you
can get the same great service you
currently have but at half the price
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
20 bucks a month
20 bucks a month the average person is
paying 400 a year for that
you could be paying 20 bucks a month
it's unbelievable
i know it sounds too good to be true but
i know these guys
it's the same exact coverage it's j you
can get unlimited talk unlimited text
two gigs of data for just 20 bucks a
month all you need to do
is grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
and say keyword michael knowles that's
pound 250 say keyword michael knowles
when you do you will save 50 off your
first month
in this crazy culture with all these
vacuous congressmen bill barr comes he
tries to speak a little common sense
and it's some common sense that we've
been trying to say on this show and i
know conservatives have been saying to
the left now for weeks
it is not acceptable to burn down the
country
i can't believe that needs to be said it
is
not acceptable to burn the country down
in to use a specific example
it's not acceptable to burn down a
federal courthouse
the democrats are shocked to hear it
that's right congressman
they're sort of distinct missions one
mission is to enforce federal law
and by the way the federal government is
the sovereign of the united states we
have two sovereigns here
uh in the united states and we enforce
the federal law all over the country
every square foot of the country
we enforce federal law the other is
protecting federal property
and specifically u.s courthouses which
are the heart of federal property in all
93 jurisdictions in the united states
and we have the obligation to protect to
protect federal courts and the u.s
marshals specifically
have been given that obligation federal
courts are under attack since when is it
okay
to try to burn down a federal court
if someone went down the street to the
prettiman court here that beautiful
courthouse we have right at the bottom
of the hill
and start breaking windows and firing
industrial grade fireworks in to start a
fire
throw kerosene balloons in and and start
fires in the court
is that okay is that okay now
no the u.s marshals have a duty to stop
that and defend
the courthouse and that's what we are
doing in portland
this was the moment probably more than
any other in the hearing where barr
becomes visibly and audibly exasperated
he's like
who are you people what you're defending
burning down federal courthouses what is
wrong with you
people and do you think it made an
impact do you think what he said
persuaded them even penetrated those
very very thick skulls that they have
no not at all not at all they are still
calling to defund the police they're
still calling to defund military
recruitment we talked about that
yesterday
they want to defund the apparatus of law
enforcement
why because they want to defund our law
they don't want us to have a country
of laws they want us to have a country
run by the ever-changing whims
of the left now in this climate is it
any surprise
that 100 police agencies have just
pulled out of the dnc
the democratic national convention such
as it is it's going to be a paired down
one
they don't have any protection they
don't have any protection now because
the cops don't want to protect them and
i got to tell you
i'm with the cops i'm with the cops here
you know i think one reaction to this to
finding out
that none of these police agencies want
to protect the dnc
one reaction is well they signed up they
got to do their job they got to protect
people even if they don't like those
people
that's not the point it's not just we
have a disagreement on this policy or
that policy
it's that the dnc is actively trying to
dismantle the police they are openly
saying this
at the most mainstream high level they
want to
dismantle the law enforcement apparatus
of this country
you cannot ask law enforcement
to participate in its own destruction
not even just because it will be
detrimental to them
but because that would be detrimental to
the entire country
to our entire system of government and
to our entire system of
law and order you you would never
ask someone to participate in their own
destruction
but that's what would happen if these
police agencies
were to protect the dnc and on a very
tangible level the the
democrats have basically said if cops
ever use force we're going to arrest
them and ruin their lives
you can't ask a guy to go into that
position it's not like cops get paid a
ton of money
right it's not as though you say well
look it's a tough job but at least they
make a ton of money
and so therefore we ask a lot of them
they don't it's service
you you they make a relatively modest
salary
and they take a on a dangerous job
and they do it because it is a noble
calling to protect people
and to enforce the law well if you're
gonna
if you're gonna punish them in some
cases you know you charge them with
murder
just for doing their job
why would they do it you can only push a
man so far
you know the the line between courage
and recklessness is a little bit blurry
sometimes
but for a cop to go out there when he
knows that the people that he's going
out to protect
are actively trying to ruin his life and
maybe throw him in jail
or worse or worse
that that's pure recklessness you can't
you can't ask a guy
to do that and so they're pulling out of
the dnc i think it makes total sense
that they are
this uh this was announced first by
milwaukee police chief
alfonso morales uh
or rather alfonso morales was the one
who was ordered last month to change the
department's policies
to basically not let them do their jobs
and so then
all in conjunction it's been announced
by these 100 law enforcement agencies
absolutely makes sense and lest you
think
lest you think that you know republicans
are trying to undermine the rule of law
here i
i don't think you would ever fall into
that trap but the mainstream media are
trying to push that idea on you
we've got a story that i think the
mainstream media are not reporting on
every time a right winger so much as
flicks the shoulder of a left winger
some
every time a right winger you know walks
up and kind of smacks a guy in the face
or something
that's a national news story how about
when
left-wingers drive their automobiles
through a crowd of conservatives
does that make the news hear about that
story probably you didn't we'll get to
that in one second
then we will get to the broader issue
here
of not not just silencing the attorney
general at a hearing
but silencing very important relevant
information
during a pandemic to serve political
purposes that's not even being carried
out by the politicians that's
being carried out by our true overlords
over in big tech we'll get to all of
that first though got to thank our
friends over at rad
power bikes rad power bikes
are absolutely fabulous for getting out
of the house
they're cool just in general they're
cool just but especially these days
they're really cool to get around to
commute
to maybe get out in nature even with the
kids in tow
you've got to try rad power bikes it's a
cross between a traditional bike and a
moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would
you go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling so you can get out and
about without getting sweaty they're
great for commuting they're great for
getting out on the trail they're great
for hauling groceries
or even transporting your kids on your
back
on the back of the bike unlike other
e-bikes they're usually
they're actually rather affordable and
to show appreciation for those that
serve us
rad power bikes is offering 100 bucks
off all e-bike purchases
for active and ex-military first
responders teachers and
students really terrific company and
especially now
what a great product rad power bikes
offer flexible financing for as low as
zero percent apr
right now is a limited time offer you
can get a free accessory with the
purchase of a bike
and you can get a free gift of up to 100
dollars in value
free shipping to the lower 48 states to
get the special offer takes the word
knoll's canoe wlas to 64 000
that is knowles kwles to 64
000. text it out right now
on july 25th
not that long ago at approximately 3 38
p.m
in eaton colorado the eaton pd responded
to a report
of a man traveling in a maroon suv
trying to drive through and over a crowd
of pedestrians
those pedestrians so usually when you
hear that headline you find oh it's
going to be a right winger probably a
white supremacist
driving through liberals and then you
find out the driver is not
a conservative or a white guy or
whatever and then the narrative kind of
goes away
well in this case they weren't driving
into
we know the we know the identity of the
crowd he was driving into they were
driving into
a blue lives matter conservative crowd
and fortunately liberals don't know how
to drive very well
so as far as i can tell nobody was
injured
that that may have changed but
fortunately the motor skills of left
wingers
not great so that's one thing we can
hang our hats on
still this guy should absolutely be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law this is the uh
this is an event run by the northern
colorado young republicans
these are acts of explicit political
violence by the left we've seen a lot of
these acts in recent years
going back to the congressional baseball
game remember when that bernie bro tried
to shoot up and murder
many congressmen at that congressional
baseball game
you see this time and time again for
explicitly
political reasons i asked yesterday on
the show
is this just the new normal you know we
talk about the new normal with kovit
like you got to wear the stupid masks
and you got whatever
i don't think that's the i think the new
normal might be political violence
there is a normalization going on of
political violence and its political
violence specifically when you
contradict
the left it's and it's i mean in this
case it's real violently you're driving
a car into a crowd
in the congressional baseball game
you're shooting people but there's a
subtler form of violence
which is you just destroy somebody's
life if they contradict
the left you you ostracize them
from society that is being undertaken
right now by the left but it's not the
politicians it's big tech right now big
tech
is now engaging in the spookiest kind of
election interference that we have seen
in a very long time maybe ever
and we also have video just recently
uncovered from some of the
top people at google explaining four
years ago
exactly what they were going to do now
we're seeing that project
come to fruition they don't want you to
see that either they're censoring a lot
of videos on the internet i hope they
don't take this one down
they probably will and we'll have to get
it out elsewhere which is why by the way
we appreciate it that you've subscribed
to the michael knoll show youtube
channel
we've got a lot of platforms here at
this show in case one of them
mysteriously goes down
we've got apple podcasts we put it on
facebook we go obviously we've got my
twitter feed
we go on youtube right we put it putting
it all over the place
so we appreciate when you can go there
ring the bell subscribe also
buy ben's book how to destroy america in
three easy steps
he did a live signing last tuesday with
me by the way
and so if you want to get a signed copy
uh because there might not be any more
left in a few days head on over to
dailywire.com
ben also get the readers pass one buck
for your first month three bucks a month
after that you get all sorts of
exclusive content great
stuff like drew's most recent
conservatives will lose the country
without god it goes really in depth here
head on over check it out dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so you saw yesterday maybe you listened
we played this video
of these doctors and white lab coats
down there in washington
giving a press conference about how
hydroxychloroquine
is effective at treating the coronavirus
which we've known for a very long time
there's been tons of evidence about this
and we've had that drug
hydroxychloroquine for years and years
and years now
then there was a study that went up that
said that hydroxychloroquine is really
bad for you
that study was retracted it was total bs
now more evidence we had a yale
epidemiologist come out just last week
in newsweek
say hydroxychloric and works very well
you can use it to treat coronavirus
left doesn't want that information
getting out because
they've already they've already sunk so
much into this
they've even beyond the kind of
conspiracy
theory perspective just just think about
from a very practical political
perspective
the left has put all their chips on
coronavirus covid is the campaign at
this point especially with the second
lockdown
they can't let that get up even if they
did find some medicine even if
hydroxychloroquine is very effective
they can't let that up businesses have
already planned out their next
year based on coronavirus they're not
going to let that up
it's frankly even the mask issue
remember i said early on
correctly that the masks are a political
symbol more than practical
medical advice so that remains true you
can see this and all the disclaimers
that that the people selling the masks
have to put on namely
that the masks don't do anything to
prevent the transmission of viruses
but i said they're very effective at the
as a political symbol
some people argued for the masks because
they said well the masks will allow us
to reopen
do you see anything reopening the more
masks we put on do you think we're
opening up more
no we're shutting down more and i
understand why some people would have
mistakenly believed that if you wear the
masks the
left will allow the government to open
and the country to reopen but it won't
it's actually the opposite
the reason is that the mask is a
reinforcing symbol
that we have to remain locked down it
operates on the same principle
as a campaign merchandise when you buy
merchandise like a t-shirt or a hat or
something
from a political campaign that you
support
a lot of people think you do that to
donate money to the campaign now it's
not about the money the campaigns don't
make
very much money at all sometimes they
lose money on the merchandise the reason
they sell you the merchandise
is to tie you to the campaign because
when you put on the t-shirt of the
candidate
you've now taken on support for that
candidate
as part of your identity your behavior
has now
shifted something in your mind to say
that you will be more supportive of that
candidate
it's the same thing with the masks this
is why even some conservatives who put
on the mask there's
there is like no evidence that the masks
do
anything the masks stop a little bit of
spittle from getting out
but unless you're talking like kenneth
branagh playing hamlet
you don't need to worry about the
spittle the reason
that even some conservatives who put the
mask on are now much more supportive of
the masks than the lockdowns
is because it's reinforcing if you wear
the mask which is such a
such an odd kind of piece of clothing
right it's an odd accessory it's an odd
symbol
then you have told yourself that this is
very real
and the more you wear it the more you're
going to believe that the more deeply
you're going to be bought into that
and so it comes as no surprise that big
tech
took down that video of a lot of doctors
who are echoing very mainstream medical
advice of some of the most
respected people in the field saying
hydroxyclaric when obviously works
they had to take it down so they took it
down on facebook they took it down on
twitter
we had to take down part of our show
yesterday
because i played that video and they
would not allow that up they are
threatening to boot you off of social
media if you permit
these doctors to speak remember we're
supposed to listen to the science well
only some scientists as i told you
months ago
has nothing to do with the science has
everything to do
with politics it's not just that that's
not the extent
of the social media censorship of
scientific voices going on or any other
kind of voices
breitbart just put this video up it's
breitbart exclusive
days after the 2016 election you had a
very high ranking fellow over at google
google vp for global affairs kent walker
come out address the first all hands
meeting after the 2016 election
it featured obviously himself it
featured the ceo of google senator
pichai
it featured the co-founders sergey brin
and larry page
and other google executives in this
meeting
we'll just play a few clips of it you
can go to breitbart watch the whole
thing
the vp here for global affairs discussed
his
dismay he discussed his disgust frankly
at the 2016 election and specifically
laid out in broad terms a plan
to combat it in 2020.
it was a shock to to all of us the
results of the election
this is not the first sign we've seen of
this rising tide
of nationalism populism and concern
well it may be that the internet and
globalization were part of the cause of
this problem
we are also fundamentally an essential
part of the solution to this problem
and it's important to recognize that
while the republicans and and the trump
administration
this trump administration they have a
majority in the senate majority in the
house they don't have a super majority
in the senate the ark does go like this
exponentially
in terms of standards of living around
the world yes it's not completely smooth
it goes up and down
and i think history teaches us that
there are periods of
populism of nationalism that rise up and
we that's all the reason we need to be
in the arena that's why we have to work
so hard to make sure
it doesn't turn into a world war
something catastrophic but instead is a
blip
is a hiccup it's a blip it's a hiccup we
got to stop this nationalism nationalism
is a really bad thing we need globalism
and that's what we here at google exist
to do is to undermine
the results of the 2016 election
undermine
the decision of the american people
undermine national sovereignty
no surprise there either google is a
globalized company citizens of the world
i don't know that google has any
particular loyalty to the united states
they certainly don't have any particular
loyalty to the american people
and they're trying google frankly on
this uh
scientist video they're the they're the
least defenders
uh compared to facebook and twitter
but they don't want that information
getting out there and twitter is
rigging twitter and facebook and google
they're all rigging
the election as part of the same
breitbart
exclusive they point out that google has
been purging breitbart content
from search results since the 2016
election they find that breitbart's
search visibility
is down 99.7
since 2016. that's the survival rate of
coronavirus by the way at least
well that's how much breitbart has been
suppressed
since 2016. google
killed basically all search traffic
to breitbart for joe biden and joe biden
related searches they're trying
as they told us they would do four years
ago they were trying to shift the
election back
to the globalist candidate the candidate
who cheered the rise of china very
recently
joe biden said it's a wonderful thing
that china's gotten more powerful
we're living through the consequences of
that right now some people haven't
learned the lesson
specifically in big tech we just have to
listen to the experts
well not the not the conservative
experts but only the experts who
go along with the left and if you
contradict them by the way
they'll say well what's your credential
are you an expert you have a phd do you
have an md
where's your credential bill barr going
back to billboard billbar in that
hearing yesterday
had such a wonderful rejoinder we should
memorize it we should remember to say it
a democratic representative mary gay
scanlan asked bill barr
about his expertise if he had a
scientific study to cite
bill barr said he had something much
more important
last month you echoed the president's
conspiracy theory when you suggested in
at least
three interviews that quote foreign
countries could manufacture
counterfeit ballots and quote to
influence the presidential election
correct you did that in at least three
interviews
yes okay but in fact you have no
evidence that foreign countries can
successfully swear elections with
counterfeit ballots do you
no i don't but i have common sense okay
well
and that's what you responded when you
were directly challenged on that
yes that is what he responded maybe you
should have listened to that
representative
but he does have common sense something
sorely lacking on capitol hill and among
the liberal establishment generally they
don't have common sense
because they're disconnected from
reality they have their ideology
they have their fantasies that they
write down in manifestos that
in no way describe the real world
they've got that
and that's the precise reason that they
don't have common sense
and it's why people who don't have fancy
degrees and phds and
all sorts of credentials that's why they
do have common sense and it's why those
people tend
to be more correct in the long run than
those ideologues it
reminds me of bill buckley's old advice
he said he would rather be governed by
the first 2000 people
in the phone book than by the faculty of
harvard college
remember that that's the idea that we
have here that's the idea of giving
sovereignty to we the people in the
united states something the left is now
explicitly
denouncing this is a scandal
what's going on in big tech is a scandal
that hearing on capitol hill was a
scandal
what they tried to do in 2016 to rig the
election was a scandal remember when
obama
weaponized his his agencies of
government
to illegally spy on the trump campaign
we've got we've got
reams and reams of evidence about this
the left barely denies it anymore what
they do
is the same thing they do every time
they say oh that's old news
oh that that one's that forget about
that that was a long time ago stop
talking about that
and then they put it down the memory
hole because they control the flow of
information valerie jarrett
top top tippy top advisor to barack
obama
went on maria bartoroma's show yesterday
and
gave the standard leftist line
maria look i have very high degree of
confidence that our intelligence
community
our investigators comported themselves
responsibly
uh look lindsey graham was the one that
encouraged senator mccain to turn over
the dossier in the first place to the
fbi
and so i can't tell you all of the
reasons why comey went forward with his
investigation
maybe this was one piece of a bigger
puzzle but i do know that it's nearly
four
years ago and i don't understand why our
focus isn't on what's happening
right now and today that's the
investigation i'd like to say
oh this was four years ago it's old news
the clintons are
i'm so excited my voice is like jumping
up and down the clintons are most famous
for using this strategy they did it all
throughout the 90s
they'd say you know i did not have sex
with that woman i didn't do it and then
you find out
a year later he did do it he goes well
look that's old news now why are we
talking about was a long time ago
come on now let's move on gotta get on
with the business of the country and the
so clinton's perfect this and the left
continues to use it
more than 20 years later that's old news
well yeah we just found out about it
though
we now have proof there's a criminal
investigation going on led by john
durham
what do you mean we got to stop talking
about this we're in the midst of a
presidential election and you people are
trying to do it again
albeit through other means
that's what's going on you feel like
you're you feel like you're bill barr
you feel like you're living in this
clown world looking around you're saying
are you
eric swoevel are you are you a real
person valerie jarrett are you seriously
saying this with you
google are you really are you really
saying these things that is the effect
of ideology that's the effect of mass
hysteria
do you really think a virus with at
least a 99.7
survival rate is worth not leaving your
home
for five months
and do you really think by the way if we
have a treatment that is effective at
treating it that we should suppress that
information
what kind of bizarro delusional fantasy
world you have to live in to believe
that
you have to live in the bizarro
delusional fantasy world of the left
greatest example of this
the teachers unions the teachers union
you thought
that the black and white selfie thing on
instagram was ridiculous
at least that one's kind of funny at
least we'll get a kick out of this
the teachers unions it's just sad
teachers unions in dc right now
they are lining up body bags outside of
school system offices to protest
having to come do their jobs because
they're saying
if we if teachers have to show up and
teach students
then they're all going to die it's going
to be a slaughter of teachers by the way
there are studies out of sweden and
finland right now where schools have
been opened
over whether the virus is even being
transmitted in the schools
no evidence that it is no evidence zero
buckets nothing
but these hysterical frivolous
ridiculous teachers in dc
are pretending that it is
the teachers are saying no we can't
we're we can't go in we're the heroes
you can't make us come in and do our
jobs
that's how powerful you know teachers
unions have been powerful for a very
long time
now we're seeing them flex that muscle
one thing i i also want to point out to
you
this is the exact same narrative from
the first wave of the virus
except for the first wave of the virus
it was the nurses that were the heroes
the martyrs the most wonderful they
shouldn't be expected to do their jobs
you got to stay home for the nurses and
then
the nurses started sending out pictures
and videos about how the hospitals were
largely empty and we never got close to
overwhelming capacity and then some
nurses started posting tick-tock videos
of them dancing in the empty hallways
and we thought okay well yikes okay the
left can't use those nurses anymore as
the emblem of why you need to stay home
and
imprison yourself in your house so then
it shifted to the teachers but it's the
same narrative
there's no it's the same idolization of
these people
it's the same no one has ever sacrificed
more than these people sacrifice
mark my words in two weeks we're gonna
get some teacher tick tock videos
and then we're gonna have to move on to
another victim group preposterous you
know how preposterous it is
the schools are not reopening in in a
great many places
so the kids are not allowed to go to
school
but they are allowed to go to the school
building
for day care up to eighth grade by the
way
so in austin texas the austin texas
independent school district has declared
all instruction will be virtual from
august 18th to september 7th
at least so the
ymca of austin has extended
its summertime essential programming
to children some children who are
teenagers
so that they can go to daycare and do
their school work their virtual school
work online
do you know where the ymca of austin is
doing this sort of thing
in the school building so they can't
it's like
i i feel like bill barr so the kids are
oh let me see if i can process this the
kids are going to the school building
but they are not allowed to be in school
but they are doing their schoolwork in
the school building
it's always sunny in washington dc it's
always sunny
in the usa that's the world we're living
in folks
upside down bizarro world are we going
to tolerate it or are we going to try to
restore some sense of order
it's all about november let's see who
comes out ahead
that's our show i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
2020. you know the matt wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen
you